yesterday I told you that we found out
according to a recent report that
Russian President Vladimir Putin was
personally connected with Russia's
hacking of the 2016 presidential
election Putin himself ordered the hack
according to this report explicitly to
hurt Hillary Clinton and help Donald
Trump win the election and there's two
important angles that a lot of people
are confused about one of those I talked
about yesterday which is David if Russia
did help Trump it didn't really get
anything out of it from the Trump
administration wrong I dealt with that
yesterday okay I want to deal with a
different angle today which is what did
Russia actually do to interfere aside
from possible collusion with Trump
associates what did Russia do to
interfere and many people say they
didn't do anything or it's vague or I
don't get it
there were four modes of infiltration
okay this includes interfering with a
well I'll just break it down for you
okay this includes making connections
inside the Trump campaign hacking the
DNC hacking voting systems and creating
propaganda inside the US number one
Russia established contact with Trump
campaign members that they believed were
sympathetic to Russia to gain influence
within the Trump campaign we know about
tons of these individuals who met with
Russian diplomats and proxies Paul
Manafort Michael Flynn Carter Paige
Kushner Jeff Sessions Roger stone those
are the ones we know about and there
could be others Michael Flynn eventually
forced to resign Jeff Sessions lied
under oath about his meetings with
Sergey kis lyac Paul Manafort being
worked for years to advance Russian
interests making millions of dollars for
himself while doing it Carter page under
investigation for visiting Russia during
the election Roger stone communicated
with a person that US intelligence
believes is directly involved with the
Russian hacks of the DNC we've got the
countless undisclosed meetings by Jared
Kushner and this worked right the RNC
actually changed its platform to be more
Pro Russia around the time of the
Republican National Convention so that's
path number one path number two Russia
hacked the DNC email servers back in
September of 2015
the FBI first noticed that Russia was
hacking the dnc Russians ultimately
hacked thousands of DNC emails to
WikiLeaks who leaked them at
strategically convenient times during
the last half of last year and some of
those were released the day before the
Democratic National Convention US Intel
thinks WikiLeaks has increasingly become
a Russian propaganda tool Trump and a
lot of his supporters say oh the DNC
should have prevented this it was their
fault the Republicans of better security
we learned that Russia also hacked the
Republican National Committee they just
decided not to release any of that stuff
so again all of this meddling with the
u.s. election was to help Trump win Path
number 3 Russia hacked us voting systems
in as many as 39 states leading up to
the election to steal voter registration
information this is a more recent
development hackers tried to delete and
alter some of that voting data leaked
NSA documents showed that hackers from
Russian military intelligence access
software designed to be used by poll
workers and accessed campaign finance
databases officials say that this data
was stolen and that it could have been
used it could be used against the US and
future elections this was almost totally
buried Pat this came out about two weeks
ago and because it was again scandal
after scandal that story we barely even
heard anything about right I mean of
course there's no evidence thus far that
Russia was able to change any votes and
I think after you know people may have
gotten fixated on that oftentimes you
hear well okay so Russia hacked 39
states but they didn't flip individual
votes that's not the argument that's
being made right we're talking about how
Russia infiltrated the voting system
that's task number three path number
four you may be more familiar with
Russia launched a ton of they basically
ran a fake news disinformation campaign
on social media and through propaganda
websites they spread lies about Hillary
Clinton and Democrats they created
endless fake Twitter accounts to spread
fake news articles they paid internet
trolls to go on social media and use web
sites to make pro-russia pro-trump
anti-hillary comments we've learned
about these troll factories in Saint
Petersburg Russia where these people
would show up in the work they were paid
by the Russian government and there's
actually a study by Oxford University
which found that about half of the news
half of the news that Michigan voters
were exposed to during the election was
fake or propaganda news we dealt with
this more extensively in our fake news
long-form video and you can find that on
YouTube if you missed it four paths
paths that Russia was involved in yeah
and what have James Comey and others
warned about that Russia's going to be
back and you know they're not
necessarily in support of Democrats or
Republicans it seems as if Putin has
some sort of penchant for Trump and
certainly hates Hillary Clinton but the
next go-around it could affect the GOP
just the same it's not even within the
US I would say you're right but think
even bigger Russia does this stuff all
over the world we're particularly
vulnerable right now because we have an
acutely incompetent administration I
don't think anyone who denies Russian
interference in the election at this
point can still be taken seriously you
can debate the impact you can debate how
should the u.s. respond you can debate
does this impact Trump's legitimacy but
to deny the interference at this point
is really not a serious position and I
believe we're going to look back at this
in years with shame looking back and
saying wow partisanship made it so that
many people ignored and obstructed a
full and fair investigation into what
didn't didn't happen and this it goes
beyond Donald Trump personally colluding
with Russian that's not what I'm talking
about right now four paths and it's it's
still something that you see many
trumpets with a vested interest in
preventing any real investigation into
merely because they don't want to feel
bad about the fact that Donald Trump is
president that's really what is
underlying all of this right and I think
we have to agree on what the problem is
so then we can take steps to try to
solve it because if Russia is able to
affect voting counts the next go-around
that would create a giant constitutional
crisis and listen I have no personal
connection to definitively proving that
Trump colluded with Russia let's
investigate it maybe he did maybe he did
I have no personal ideological interest
and saying Russia did or didn't do X Y
or Z I just want the truth and I'm
following what we know and what our
intelligence agencies are telling us and
what the great investigative reporting
is turning up I just want to get to the
truth don't obstruct us getting to the
truth and then let's figure out what the
truth is and deal with that send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show we'll be back after this